[Music]
Let's do it Black Kabuto Let's
go
[Music] It
's the
first time I've seen so many people Maybe
you've never left that island
Yeah It's the first time I've been to Memorial
[Music]
[MUSIC]
Fate It
tastes pretty good
This soup
is a combination of multiple
ingredients If it's not something that anyone can make
It would be interesting if you could make me
a scorpion's leg meat.  I
wonder if there's a need to judge not to break that kind of
monopoly Another thing is that
Sandy Shell needs nursing care
Sundae Shell that makes good soup is
n't rare around
here Come back here and rent a kitchen
Collect the best ingredients
I can't help it. Shall I go out with you?
If so, you guys
came to the west cove at
3:00.
[music]
This guy found it so easily
It's past 3 o'clock
Nothing will come out even if you praise him Chopper
Next time you should get scorpion leg meat
But scorpion
Where are you
?  What's wrong, Nami-san
, I thought I had a rough idea of ​​Alabasta's terrain, but I shouldn't have, right?
[music]
OK, I'm going to kill all the scorpions around here
You don't need to be so enthusiastic
I'll do my best to the scorpion's legs
[music]
I can't help it  Or
Leave it to me
[Music]
I'll decide in one shot
People go
[Music]
Gum-Gum's [Music] Someone who seems to know someone [Music] [Music] You're going with a sword storm
Do it
[music]
Let's
do it [music] Do it
[music]
Go Thunderbolt
Train and Fleur
No matter how many things there are, it's already the same time
Music]
Let's go Wayo-sized gun It's a
worthwhile opponent to cut It's a
hindrance After
that, it's okay to leave it to
us That's it, we're winning We don't need
to be so enthusiastic about being called a monster
Hey,
scorpion's leg meat  'Cause one is enough
[music]
Arms clapping
This is the dish I made
Interesting
This savory taste is from the Sunday shell
And this meat  The gravy tasted
like miso.The
fact that it wasn't so popular means that the delicious
smell lured me in.
Luffy, I didn't know you were here.
Ace,
what are you doing
?  Music]
Let's talk while eating, okay then,
Sanji,
leave it to me,
Flare Flare Fruit Power User.
I was
proud of my skill.
Come
back, Luffy,
I'll be waiting for you on the heights
[Music]
Watch me I'll
definitely
become the Pirate King
Alright everyone let's
go to the desert
[music]